[Musique]
au camping des saules impossible de se
passer de la piscine
c'est 240 mètres cubes ont été remplis
en février aujourd'hui l'arrêté
préfectoral autorise uniquement le
renouvellement partielle de l'eau
on se doit de faire des lavages de
filtres réguliers pour garantir la bonne
hygiène des contrôler tous les mois par
la RS et donc pour garder
un supplémentaire notre système permet
d'apporter juste le minimum nécessaire
pour garantir cette bonne qualité
dans ce camping labellisé que les verte
on fait la chasse à la moindre économie
d'eau jusque dans les toilettes
alors la particularité est simple ils
sont sans eau c'est à dire que chaque
urinoir n'est pas connecté sur le réseau
d'eau ce qui permet l'économie de 50 ml
d'eau par an par une raie noire on en a
10 sur le camping en fait le calcul
c'est 500000 d'eau d'économiser
annuellement
ici les douches sont minutées le débit
des robinets est réduit les eaux de
pluie sont récupérés pour l'arrosage des
espaces verts de petits gestes plutôt
efficaces un camping comme le mien
devrait consommer 5000 mètres cubes
d'eau par an avec les efforts et
l'installation on consomme 3500 mètres
cubes soit 42% d'économie d'eau
manuellement l'ADN du camping c'est
d'être au contact avec la nature et le
sens pour nous il est aussi citoyen
c'est à dire que un camping va être
respectueux de la ressources si on veut
la partager avec les visiteurs donc
c'est vraiment c'est un sens important
pour nous dans notre développement
parmi les clients de Laurent Cherrier
beaucoup d'habitudes comme ce couple
d'Anglais chez eux aussi il y a des
restrictions
je dirais que ça fait partie des choses
qui arrivent en ce moment on doit
simplement faire attention qu'on soit en
vacances ou pas on doit surveiller les
ressources en eau qui sont limitées
doit faire attention à sa consommation
d'eau dans un contexte de sécheresse
mais cette année les restrictions sont
particulièrement tôt et elles dureront
probablement jusqu'à sa fermeture en
septembre